I've been thinking a lot about Garland
Texas and the Prophet Muhammad cartoon
contest where two men who tried to
attack it were shot dead and I just feel
like where does it end and every time I
want to throw my hands up and watch a
baby wombat video I remember Pam Geller
Pam Geller is the president of the
sponsors of the cartoon contest the
American freedom Defense Initiative and
you could say hates Muslims
professionally
she's already run ads in New York City
in Washington DC in the ads call for
stopping aid to Muslim countries these
religious leaders should look towards
the hateful Islamic texts and teachings
that call for the annihilation of the
Jewish people we have a president who
was aligned with the jihad force she
claims to care about free speech kind of
like lenny of mice and men cares about
his puppy he's always killing him by
petting him too hard which is giving her
way too much credit
she's show off the right wing rails that
even foxnews tried to convince her she
was being unnecessarily provocative you
don't do it in a in a crass crude way by
insulting someone's religion you do it
by rising above that and saying we are
not like you and that would be from Fox
News's book of ethics on page and it
looks like she's just taunting everybody
what did she do it was a drawing
Mohammed Donald Trump thought she was
tasteless and that's the comb-over
talking in her defense Geller compared
herself to none other than civil rights
legend Rosa Parks what would he have
said about Rosa Parks Rosa Parks should
never have gone to the front of the bus
oh Gellar has a dream too bad it's also
our pantsless recurring nightmare like
this debate with hardline Isis supporter
unjam Chaudhary the fact is that you're
insulted the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
taala
and obviously you knew the consequences
otherwise you wouldn't
consequences it's like a shrill sequel
to predator versus alien can't we just
shoot him back into space but if Pam
Geller is all about free speech you got
to ask where was she when Occupy Wall
Street was being shut down for speaking
out about inequality or when peaceful
protesters in Ferguson were met by tanks
in a Time magazine op-ed she says that
hate speech is subjective and censorship
is civilizational suicide making her the
philosophical guru of youtube comment
trolls
don't delete my comment about you being
an ugly that's Sharia she also writes if
a group will not stand for being
offended without resorting to violence
that group will rule unopposed while
everyone else lives in fear except
radical Muslims don't rule the u.s. in
fact I can only think of one group
people fear that rules unopposed and
gets pretty violent when offended the
police then went loss for words they
actually can't read the words that were
published by the White House hours
before on their website even said